I want to show you guys this map real
quick this is the total vote count
I don't know if you guys knew this but
did you know that Republicans won the
popular vote
52.2 million to 47.2 million yet somehow
the Democrats and uh uh staving off this
Red Wave uh of the total votes that was
101 million so certainly not as much as
2020
um or even as much as 2016. it's a
midterm so I'm not surprised but uh
Republicans won the popular vote
well that's really incredible so when
they say that Trump is the problem that
Trump was dragging the Republicans down
it's absolutely not true they did better
than Democrats with all of the Maga
candidates and Trump support I think
it's a little bit hard to say because we
still don't it's hard to quantify the
amount of people that just hate him
religiously hate him as the ultimate
Evil and just will not vote for because
he's gotten involved so it's a little
hard to quantify that but the point is
either way Republicans did get more
votes and if again look at that that's
sort of like looking at the New York map
that thing's pretty freaking red and yet
we're pretty much controlled by them I
love this because what they end up
coming out and saying is it's because
land doesn't vote yeah
and I'm like okay let me explain food
let me it certainly does and there's two
things to point out first the
Republicans got more votes than you
Democrats that right there so when
you're like land it doesn't vote then
how do you justify losing the pot
popular vote this time and celebrating
your Victory hypocrisy no look I
recognize that the way the district
system is because it's not going to be
fixed for eight years when the new
census comes in because of all the
people who moved around and everything
like that there's a reason why this a
state is red or district is red it's
because land does grow food the problem
that I experienced when I went to
California is because they at a state
level they don't have a represent
representative system they have just you
vote yeah in to Larry County they ran
out of water
and the Farms the farmers were drilling
thousands of feet into the Earth for
groundwater the poor migrant workers
their homes ran dry their Wells stopped
working because the cities voted we get
the water
the surface water was given to the big
cities well because they needed more but
in reality what happens is if you have
one state and you say okay everybody
vote should we allow people to keep the
water that that's in their area or
should we allow uh should we have all
the water transferred to the cities okay
everybody now vote guess what two wolves
and a lamb deciding on what's for dinner
and the big city with its 13 million
people in LA county or whatever said we
vote to get your water they voted away
water from these other from these other
places that's why land has protections
because people live there and their
resources need to be protected based on
their interests yeah I mean you just
drive north from La go to drive from New
York to San Francisco and the amount of
signs you see on all of the Farmland hey
what are you guys doing to our water
basically it the proof's the right there
San Francisco you said New York to San
Francisco L.A to San Francisco you know
I'd love to see you know these people
don't understand what happens when uh
the Great Lakes get voted away from the
Great Lakes region there's a lot of
people who live up there there's a lot
more people who don't and a lot more
people on the west Coast who are dealing
with water crises and they want that
fresh water and they don't care how they
get it so let's put it up to a vote
Chicago Indiana Ohio Michigan and then
see how long the Great Lakes last when
Arizona says don't know much problem
don't care about your problem we thirsty
because there's already been issues
going back 10 20 years where Western
States who are in drought say they have
they have a right to the Great Lakes
which are an American Resource and one
of the only things that's stopping them
from actually getting it is Canada
Ontario which is part of the Great Lakes
Coalition this is why I'm like hey
there's a reason why Illinois has rights
over their resources you can't vote them
away from them because it would destroy
it but if you don't live there why would
you care you know you want to strip the
resource for yourself it would be it
would be a disaster if we did everything
through direct democracy
the Democrats want it when you know when
in 2020 when you know they are in 2016
or in uh
when they have the popular vote but not
the presidential election but they don't
say anything about it now when the
Republicans have the pop have the
popular vote but not the majority well
the strong majority win okay it just
seems obvious to me we're just going to
have places that function in places that
don't and they're going to keep going
and the places and then they'll Purge
all their people as you're saying right
so the think about how many it's not
just that 500 000 people left New York
it's the type of people that leave it's
people that have the resources to leave
that are like that are functioning that
are looking at the numbers and going boy
it just doesn't make sense here the fact
that I'm saving money by living in
Florida now is crazy to me I didn't move
because of taxes I was willing to pay it
you know La was nice I had a nice
operation there but the fact that now
I'm saving all this money too is crazy I
would have paid that money to get in and
now I'm going to push the scientist to
go Florida I wasn't willing to pay that
money especially in New York City paying
city tax state tax federal tax until you
got out right I mean that's the point
yeah and now you go holy cow I'm in
Florida and it's better and I'm saving
the money too and how is it how is it
that Florida has roads isn't that
bizarre Florida has roads despite no
income tax Florida has better schools
property taxes no income tax no but the
property tax yes they do have high
property taxes but it's not it's
certainly not making up for what they're
losing in income tax at the end of the
year where they just take 10 of your
money or whatever it might be so Florida
declare independence and then uh
I don't want to the great Republic of
Florida I don't want to draft anything
today the day before Trump announces I'm
thinking about like what do you do when
there's one big lake that a bunch of
states are pooling from like you want to
vote locally because no reason Nebraska
should be able to vote Away Great Lakes
water that makes no sense but at the
same time there's where you unification
of States there's no reason that
Nebraska should be not have access to
the state water so we're kind of in a I
mean the bigger problem actually is that
we're just we're in a massive culture
War as you guys know these people live
in another planet than us there are
people that want to be locked down there
are people who wanted to be injected and
force other people to be injected and at
the same time say my body my choice
they're we are living in completely
separate worlds and how you put those
people together mentally you know sort
of spiritually and mentally to live in a
country but then physically do it too it
may just be too big of a problem we
gotta mention uh The Young Turks
have you seen have you seen uh but this
this you know I don't comment on on The
Young Turks or other leftist common
commenters as any kind of drama or
anything like that I think there's a
really interesting political point to be
observed in genk yuger's tweets and uh
the production path he's taking you
notice that he interviewed Matt Gates
oh I know did it happen because didn't
the lights go out oh yeah well they got
them back out but at the very least he
announced he would be interviewing Matt
Gates and people I'm sure that went well
he came out against defund the police
which is a dip a stark contrast from his
initial position in 2020 supporting
defund the police who Jank yeah but
he'll take any position you know it's
like that's the point look
he was he was going where the popular
context was right the popular position
in 2020 The Narrative was deep on the
police who's all on board I'm not going
to drag him for changing his opinion
I'll just say all right thank you Jank
for for adopting the appropriate
position again I think there's police
reforms we absolutely do need I'm not
the biggest fan of law enforcement but
that right just be I get rid of cops is
nuts now he's coming out with Anna and
they're saying things like we shouldn't
do this there are rumors about why that
is I guess wait shouldn't do what get
rid of the police oh so they're both
saying it they're both saying it's a
crazy problem you shouldn't do it and
that says something it says something
about the the shift in politics that's
occurring right now and you know I'll
put it this way when you did that you
know why I left the left thing Prager
you was massive yeah they started coming
after you saying oh he's faking it he's
a grifter and all that stuff and then we
mentioned this early on in the show here
you are in Florida in your studio ever
successful and The Young Turks power
went out and they had to complain about
how the mayor has failed them and it's
like like it's amazing if they saw what
you saw or at the very least they did
but if they accepted that it was true
and were willing to say what is true
they would not be in a place where their
power is going out and now they're
changing their opinions though yeah so I
mean I have no need to really talk about
them but I would say that I swear to you
with every fiber of my being that all I
did was do what I thought the right
thing was along the way and then make
the choices according so I started
talking to people that were that were
different than me right like they every
day they'd be saying Ben Shapiro and
Larry Elder and Dennis Prager and Glenn
Beck they're racist about uh and it was
like all right well let me talk to these
guys and see what happens and then I
start talking to them and I go boy well
I guess I do disagree with them on some
stuff and I still have certain
absolutely you have disagreements with
them on a bunch of different things but
they're nice they're generous obscureate
they're kind they want to live in a
country with people that are different
than them and then I just kept going
down that road and then you and then you
know this too because you did the same
thing you go down that road long enough
and then you're like well wait a minute
now I want my life to fit with that so I
don't want to just have a set of
political ideas I wanted live those
political ideas so for me that was
fighting as freaking hard as I could in
Cali for the recall recall was a
disaster I campaigned with Larry Elder
you know I got audited by the state
three days after the recall wow yeah so
this is what happens in Cali that's what
they do and that was the day I had
wanted to leave for about a year but I
was really trying you know the riots had
gone right by my house so I actually
moved because I was like if I move up
the hill maybe I'll be a little safer
but whatever I think and then I got the
hell out and now and now it's working
because I because I followed the true
path I really believe that I think uh
there's similarities and a bit of
differences between how we sort of
approached it for me I'd put it like I
grew up in Chicago and there's no
Republican party so the only thing you
know is Democrats and you hate them
as a young person growing up uh it was
an Arco Punk far left skateboarding
Etc and the Democrats were evil and we
didn't really know much about
Republicans my friends they there's
there's no there's no Republicans it
just doesn't happen and you got in the
suburbs and you're like there there was
no when I grew up I had no negative
thoughts about Republicans because they
were non-existent it did not impact for
the most part anything going on because
it's super majority Democrat across the
board so when I get older
I end up meeting a bunch of people on
the suburbs outside of the city who are
Republican and I have no ill will or ill
thoughts toward them because they did
not play a factor in in urban Chicago
living and then I started hearing their
opinions and and I'm like at this point
I'm eating chicken dinner with my
friends family who are conservative and
I don't know anything and I'm like oh
and so then I start shifting
from this young urban you know
skateboarding far Lefty activist into
more of like a moderate liberal position
where I'm like okay I totally understand
what these people are saying never
actually talk to him about it and then
as I get older what do you see you see
the media's lying they lie more they lie
more they lie more they lie more and
then what ends up happening is it's not
so much that people decide to become
conservative but that conservative
became a much bigger tent so I go to the
deplorable in 2017 and two people are
there they're like Tim we're big fans
and I was like really I was like I
didn't know I had a bunch of trump
supporting fans like no no we're
occupied we were big Bernie Bros but now
that it's Trump saw the same thing that
red pill is a beautiful thing man but it
wasn't so much that these people were uh
I mean they were they were liberal
hippies yeah but Bernie Sanders was
their choice and with no Bernie but
certainly not going to be Hillary
Clinton Trump was the other guy who was
talking about fixing our borders and
bringing jobs back and protecting unions
so he was the guy so people end up
voting for him not because they're far
right
but because he was closer to their
values as a populist and then of course
the weird insane cult left accuses
anybody who opposed them of being right
wing so now all of a sudden you and I
are conservative I guess I mean you may
have actually gotten more uh
conservative yeah well I well first off
I'm not by no stretch am I a traditional
conservative by the way anyone
understands the word conservative I mean
I wrote a book my first book was a
complete defense of Classical liberalism
and you know if you went through
everything in my book it's all the stuff
that Bill Maher would agree with I just
don't think he can stand on its own
anymore so I do think we do need a new
alliance and we're doing it right now of
sort of ex-libs and conservatives and
Libertarians and and caps and all of
these people uh it's basically we all
have to save the country and then we'll
deal with our problems after I think
that's basically where we're at you know
regarding As Trump the guy this is kind
of we talked about the beginning of the
segment well what happens is you know
when you try and start your car while
it's already going and it just like
Trump was The Spar Mark trying to spark
the machine right now is not the move
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time